what was I looking at this morning that
was making me laugh it was um oh do you
see that thing with the mayor do you see
that thing with mayor with the mayor of
New York no
I'll it's a um oh yeah this is it right
here do you see this so Eric Adams he
teaches what was he saying they're
teaching kids how to they're teaching
parents how to search your kids' room to
find drugs and gun stuff get you see
this you can look at a jewelry box a
jewelry box of this nature maybe a
simple jewelry box but if you look
through it closely you don't know what
your child may be hiding for instance
that's from the state of New York
government like make it scary as [__]
hold on hold on start it over they yeah
that music is crazy scare the [__] out
of these people it's like it almost
seems like a um like the story before
Castlevania starts like on a video game
jewelry box a jewelry box this is
opening menu May simp box but if you
look through it closely you don't know
what your child may be hiding for
instance a gun look at picture frames
behind them cameras try to determine
what's what's taking place behind a
picture frame you can find bullets you
should always your child this is a video
game that's where you find bullets in
video games look through it to see look
through his navag you might find a
grenade in addition to a book something
simple as a crack pipe something simple
as a as a baby doll what great is a kid
baby doll but also it could be a place
where you can secrete or hide drugs your
overr see this is the May that's unusual
like a pull like this with the button is
a perfect invitation to hide something
and I felt something bumpy I will reach
in see what it is
justes bro you guys have got to slow
stop man you guys have to see this I
mean it's just that's unbelievable look
at this where's wait where's the cocaine
at high cocaine you can look in a
jewelry box a jewelry box I like it more
than just books to Jewel
just look and see what's inside your
bookcases it more just books perect this
is like black clue
crazy call me [__] Colonel Mustard
look behind this picture of your cousin
what's that a eightball some
suppositories he's like oh look in look
in this baby doll what's in there a
shank a picture of Andy dof frame it's a
good kid I mean he's got guns and a
printer yeah oh it's a nice room yeah
it's like oh oh look under that Nintendo
switch oh what's that bam it's a 12
gauge and some tramad doll now and lers
he got a lot of guns dud um that's
pretty awesome that's pretty awesome man
he's a good I like him Eric Adams yeah
he seems funny yeah seems
good yeah I think he obviously seems
down Earth he's willing to do that yeah
you know because that seems like it
could be like a sketch you know somebody
I think that was a sketch you think who
where's that from no that's real it
feels like Reno is that's real when did
that's old though I don't know how that
has to be old there's no way New York it
was tweeted out like this week and
that's why I got the round I don't mean
to punch holes in it cuz if that just
came out that looks like it's from 20
years ago it looks like that was yeah
check your son's Invisalign case he may
be hiding uh shotgun shells or just
bullets bullets yeah look behind that
autograph picture of Katie Perry oh
what's that that's a Gatling gun and
some foxies oh you you think it's just
your child's retainer case but open it
up and Bam it's an indentured servant
and some quot that is good for yeah
honky parents need to be doing this also
what do you mean like just you need to
find they need to find the weapons yeah
did your parents ever check your I'm
trying to think of my mom H my mom came
in one time and I remember I was
touching myself right big
surprise and
uh she's like what
what are you
doing that's what she said she shamed
you yeah she's like what are you
doing like and I was kind of sitting on
the bed it was almost like very almost
as if like in the 1800s you'd wandered
upon like a a guy who was like a j like
a Jester traveling in the woods and he'
taking off his suit and he's jerking off
on by the river bank or whatever you
know and she's like what are you doing
and I was like get out out yeah and so
then she closed the door right she
waited like two seconds right I
continued masturbating she came right
back in also quick update the Eric Adams
video was from 2011 when he's a senator
it went reviral still a senator doing
that is yeah KFC posted it on bar stool
yeah check inside of your son's baseball
bat man he could be hiding a couple of
Vikings in
there it's [__] ridiculous you know
look under your little daughter's pillow
she could have some uh hookers escorts
under there like what check under the
bed found you there a [__] under there
yeah you oh you think that's a boogy man
under your son's bed that's some Boogie
[__] that's a [__] that's an escort
right there the khakis are so nice in
that video khakis and a blazer just
there could be bullets in there oh you
think that's a stuffed ludicrous doll
but open up its back and boom what do
you got a butt balloon of crystal and a
couple of Naran
chewables oh what's that in your
daughter's bedroom what's that in the
base oh that's extra taxes that's what
taxes dude yeah that's taxes and a
couple of Somas bro like damn a lot of
taxes up there check through your
child's coloring books easily in there
they could have a couple ninja stars and
a bear trap that guy's out of his
[__] mind that's good stuff well now
you think it's just an empty bottle of
Prime on your child's window sill we'll
open it up and Bam there's some homemade
lean topped off with a little mini cache
of nerve gas who was that for dude
that's Eric dude
yeah who's [__] K was that Hunter
Biden's room yeah that's crazy yeah that
actually was H yeah oh what's this here
that's a My Little Pony no that's a my
little fentol
stash